hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the
things in the night okay
I am much recovered from my last
adventure into this and I've got the
fourth-floor clear and I'm ready to rock
I had a I had to backtrack a bit because
my save dumped me for some reason my
currency would corrupted or something oh
I thought but like this for things
falling down something the dogs at my
door again okay okay what is the deal
what done oh no - I thought I don't know
what the deal is with all these barrels
but what
okay I'm utterly confused at this yes
maybe lag okay
oh I see now man I tell you some things
have been going kind of funny with this
I don't know why he's in orbit what I
picked up his heart
why is heart oh yeah the father lost his
heart maniacal murdering maniac
I can't think of any more M words
neither I hate this house I hate this
house a lot everything about it is just
disturbing
okay no monster seemed to be chasing me
mr. dad man doesn't seem to be angry
that I took his heart but maybe he'll
confront the outside hey guys how's it
hanging everyone is dead what happened
here I must get away from this place oh
yeah there wasn't even a single loading
screen in the entire house
probably why there was it was all good
better than some
any word from mr. dad man Plaza I'll
have your heart so I got two of the
three things that I needed I've already
seen that yeah yeah they're all dead and
naked for some strange reason but mostly
dead and mostly naked in fact entirely
naked yeah pretty sure anyway got the
heart I got the dagger I've already
placed the dagger before he plays the
heart see ya I already checked under
these stairs I remember it's been a
while that house took quite a bit of
time to get all this stuff required and
I'm back here this is a lovely piece of
architecture down see you are the father
you used to love your heart what that
that's not what I picked up not even it
don't even close man okay whatever got
the knife and now it's your turn
source of your power you know not really
that powerful of me okay there was
something under stairs and something
above the stairs like all this I could
have gone down one at any time
ah the real lab I gotcha all right let's
see what the real lab has in store for
me a long loading screen so I'm assuming
it is gonna be a lot of stuff oh how was
it as long as the other one this is very
fun Umbra hello Don them that didn't
look like a lot animal dr. herb I don't
know how this is possible
doctor finished somehow discovered how
to make static electricity to power
machines and to make the lights turn on
and off is called some of the best
scientists from around the world
including me dr. herb to help him build
a machine able of making this static
let's see how it goes and this seems all
pretty pretty sophisticated firm
old it was I mean
lighting lab coats but at least they're
not naked that is always a plus I see
you there
love down them kind of low down among
electricity coursing through the air and
yes of course I have to open everyone I
wouldn't I wouldn't you some sort of
medical room all there's the naked dead
guys whoa haha what everybody test or
something oh goodness gravy hi there
mr. doctor got his just desserts all
right whoo this desk looks fancy maybe
yes no yes yes yes no work amnesia might
be custom cool if it is that was Mises
door blowing multicolors oh that's why
oh I thought it was just a graphical
error but that's for serious aha I see
that dr. silver I got a telegram from
dr. Finn telling me that he had come up
with an idea about a machine meant for
static electricity so I went there as
soon as I could
I've been here for a month and I'm
mamama say the machine is something of
pure genius and it is working like a
charm things were going so well but then
dr. Finn started to lock down some areas
of the lab like a douche and has us
trapped in here with some type of
monster thirsting for our blood the rest
of the note is burnt
why fire here idea I don't know why
anything is the way it is right now but
of course there is a monster fancy
not bad
pretty good in fact I like it it's your
amazing magical static electricity gizmo
so I can jump down
probably not a good idea
it's just sad death not even not even
like a monster spawn or anything like
that it's just sad why would they want
why would they allow take the railing
off if they didn't expect people to jump
down
that's just silliness thinking that I'm
better than that
all right I just lost some time because
I made up but actually I want to come
back here because there are these other
doors then I will try locked let me
guess this other one is loved it doesn't
even say the lock sound screw you door
no one willing to anyway just like you
and you and you and you why do I get the
feeling like this is the beginning of
Aperture Science and this is where all
their dastardly experiments go on
as it was some work with portals earlier
probably
whoa holy crap why it reminds me of
levels from doom like the original doom
you know you'd have guys hanging up on
the wall at random boys but why that's
weird it's like totally weird Punk oh I
can't move my mouse Oh
I can't move anything what don't what
was that that was weird I've never seen
anything like that Wow
you know you you think people would be
more worried about a fire just all
sudden breaking out everywhere so but I
guess not this guy I see dr. Janet Myers
at least his doctor has a normal name
there's no way this is happening we are
locked down here with some monsters and
he's hidden something really big on the
other side of the glass hall walkway
that no one has ever seen this thing
must be destroyed and so I put the key
in my office in the East Wing of the lab
but first you will need the dr. Silver's
key the dr. Silver's key it's in one of
the lab rooms up ahead watch yourself in
there the place has been overrun with
demons from hell
now I must escape from here I think this
really is dude what what is my screen
flash that's a month what's the deal
what's the dealio here's some ice cream
you like flashy
why I hear you where are you to that how
about a chair to the face huh yeah Wow
didn't realize he was right there still
look at that chairman it's totally an
interesting chair I know sorry about the
flickering I don't know why that's
happening
[Music]
okay movies no I got a text message hmm
it's so interesting
hey binder nope hmm where am I gonna get
it oil doesn't seem like the place that
would just have oil it seems much more
monitor what what uh
okay ah man seriously what is the deal
I'm so confused right now I mean it's
really cool I'm not knocking I'm just
confused at why the sudden change of
pace from what is that sudden change of
pace so you little babies
vodka plays a sudden change of pace from
and total change is setting it's almost
unnerving the rapid changed I mean I'm
all about these are real ones these
aren't just the dead ones these are the
real ones
again okay
alright ok screw that
all this promotes good hello
Oh odd key keys so strange but
apparently it's to the East Wing of the
lab that's so weird that it is that way
that it is wait a minute haven't I been
in here we know I have it I'm not know
I'm going crazy there's got to be like
secrets buried in oil there's got to be
secret buried in here but I don't feel
like going through every single one of
them
[Music]
maybe this odd key no nevermind then
screw you I'll go on my own merry way
I'll make my own door and own secret
room blackjack and hookers
oh maybe this one nope
ah that's a lie was there nothing else
down here that had that I suppose not I
got a key good
oh that would make sense that the doors
in the beginning with the other doors
are climbing since if I just went to
other one it's okay
and any minute now okay there we go
kongtong alright I'm actually all out of
time for this episode so it's gotten
really really different I kind of like
it
so anyway thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always we'll see you
in the next part
bye bye